[Music]
Bakula put in some sauce on it singing
and playing Dan on the hit CBS series
NCIS New Orleans that there's no horse
rolls there's a time traveler on quantum
leap and captain Jonathan Archer on Star
Trek Enterprise he stars a special agent
Dwayne pride in NCIS New Orleans this
series will air its 100th episode
tomorrow night go you Scott in this clip
and agent pride gets involved in an
investigation that hits very close to
home so we got four dead white
nationalists out in the middle of
nowhere
why did sheriff call NCIS they didn't I
did they want to look inside to him this
used to be an old boat yard ran out of
business few years ago looks like
someone used this container for storage
storage for what buncha kids toys not
just any kid
[Music]
he's oh that's a good little tease there
Scott Bakula back in the tables or my
books I read the hardy boy bite it
absolutely did you I wasn't expecting
you to say that why why because I don't
know too many boys who read Nancy Drew I
don't did you read Nancy Joe I think so
but I can't remember that I read them in
real time or read them I love the Hardy
Boys and Nancy Drew and Bobbsey Twins
all that good stuff but we're gonna talk
about you okay let's start with the
100th episode because this is a big deal
for you Scott this is quite a milestone
it is thank you very much
mean to you well I've never gotten here
before I've been on a lot of shows that
have I've guessed it on so you get
quantum leap was 97 hours enterprise was
98 hours so I was very superstitious
when we got close to 200 that we weren't
gonna get there and of course two days
before we almost finished our hundredth
episode that hurricane was coming up the
Gulf yeah and I was headed for New
Orleans I said this is ridiculous and
it's gonna wipe out the studio I'm still
not gonna get to a hundred so but now
you're saying you the show and you have
reached your creative stride what does
that mean exactly when you say shows
take a long time to figure themselves
out and characters out and we've had we
have unfortunately had a lot of ups and
downs in our four years we have we've
lost people
we've people have left the show it's
been a very rock it's the most rocky
kind of show time that I've ever had so
we've had a little bit of peace and
quiet and then of course I say that and
it's changed again in the last couple of
weeks but there's a lot going on on the
planet right now and and it's all good
it's changed and things need to happen
but it's it's affected us tremendously
so we're plowing where we just keep our
head down and try and do our good work
and do that and stand up for all of the
things that we need to stand up for and
so is part of this surprise that's in
that one this 100th episode what we just
saw that clip finding your box with your
old toys in it that's part of the
surprise yeah at the beginning of the
season at the end of last season I was
shot three times everybody thought I was
going to England
I live yes so surprised
with a flight attendant I was coming
back from Europe and I was going to New
World and since she said please tell me
are you alive I said where are we going
going in Orleans it but are you alive I
said I'm not going to tell you could be
forever
no so I survived that but I had I come
back with PTSD I had a near-death
experience I have a relationship with
the Angel of Death which has been an
interesting thing that we've sprinkled
through and I'm flashing back on
different elements of my life
so we've we're dealing with that and
it's kind of fun season five to kind of
take a little side trip and explore some
different things different sides of
pride and his character in his history
your character also has a relationship
with your real-life wife yes it's a
family affair talk about working with
your wife Jill to feel jealous he's
great we've worked together before it's
not the first time but there she is and
I absolutely adore having her there
because I commute basically back and
forth between LA and New Orleans so when
she's down there I have her you know to
myself and I'm so we get time together
during the season which we don't get a
lot of and most importantly she she
works me she's a she really she makes
sheep she pushes me to be better because
she's basically she's a a more
disciplined better actor than I am and
so she's always asking me questions and
she's leading me to discoveries and on a
show you don't really get to work on a
TV show you don't really rehearse you
don't you just go and so we because
we're live together we can talk about
things we can fly on the plane and talk
about a scene and what do you want to do
and what good so we get a lot more
opportunity to explore things and in
that exploring I I do better work well
so I'm very lucky you look good together
but I wonder what wives are together
when you're looking at each other are
you really looking could you really know
her were you acting well it depends on
the situation I guess it's a combination
yeah no we're not thinking about yeah
my pleasure rats episode of NCIS New
Orleans airs tomorrow 9:00 at 10:00 for
tonight at 10:00 9:00 central here on
CBS